Welcome to the mini project on k-means clustering.
You know a lot about k-means clustering at this point, but
it's been all on sort of made up datasets for pedagogical purposes.
Now you're going to be doing k-means clustering on real data,
in this case, the Enron finance data.
And as we sometimes do in the second part of the mini project, we're going to
give you a sneak peak at the next lesson, which is on feature scaling.
Feature scaling is some pre-processing that you can do on your features, and
it will actually change the output of your clustering algorithm after you've
performed feature scaling.
So you'll get an idea of what's at stake when you do something like that